So after months and months and months and
months and months, seven months, lawmakers
have finally agreed to a second coronavirus
stimulus and they have not yet voted on it.
They've agreed on it. The House and Senate
still need to vote on it. But in this story,
I'll tell you everything that you might be
getting and also what big business is getting
and what nobody's getting, which is very,
very important. Sadly, this is mostly too
little, too late. Like, if you want to just
click off and go to a different story. It's
mostly too little, too late. And you'll see
why momentarily. But let's dig into it. The
package in total is 900 billion dollars. It
will include 600 dollar payments to adults
earning up to 75000 dollars, with the possibility
of an additional 600 per dependent child living
at home. Although the language and the specifics
on that may still change, it's not completely
clear. Restarted enhanced unemployment will
be in place for 300 dollars per week for 11
weeks. Remember, the original enhanced unemployment
was 600 a week. This will be 300 a week. There
will be 284 billion dollars for businesses.
The program will be restarted. There will
be expanded eligibility for nonprofits, newspapers,
radio and TV broadcasters, 15 billion for
performance venues and independent movie theaters,
which are essentially shut down in total,
saves some rare examples that have figured
out how to do sort of like mask required.
Everybody gets tested on the way in types
of things. There will be money for testing
and tracing 82 billion dollars for colleges
and schools, which many people have an issue
with the idea of some of these largely well-endowed
schools getting money when they don't even
really need to be charging tuition. They could
pay for everybody's tuition with the interest
on their endowments. That's a problem for
some 13 billion dollars for nutritional assistance,
seven billion for broadband access, 25 billion
for rental assistance and an extended eviction
moratorium. So basically, it's too little,
too late. And the devil is in the details
with a lot of these line items, for example,
just to pick one seven billion dollars for
broadband support.
How exactly does that work? Is it just a cash
grab for ISPs or is it actually reimbursements
for people who sign up for Internet service?
How is that that it's all in in the details?
Because these programs can either be beneficial
or slush funds for big corporations or both.
Admittedly, it can be it can be both. Now,
is it better than nothing? Well, yeah, of
course. Of course. With the caveat that sometimes
doing something crappy is used as an excuse
to not do anything else. So if I have a gunshot
wound and you hand me a Band-Aid, is the Band-Aid
better than nothing if more help is coming?
Well, yeah, it might be the Band-Aid might
do something for me for two minutes until
we get real treatment. But if handing me the
Band-Aid is all we do, well, then I'm going
to be screwed. And it's been seven months
since the last stimulus package. People are
getting half the cash payment and half the
enhanced unemployment. And now I I've been
getting voicemail's over the weekend from
people who seem to think the reason I did
a segment last week advocating for more. There's
people who seem to think I'm advocating for
more so that I will get more of something
I I don't even know that I need to do this.
But I will mention that I am getting nothing.
I got nothing last time and neither did my
business. I'm getting nothing this time and
neither is my business. I'm not arguing for
even a single dollar for myself. I'm getting
zero either way. So it's half the benefits
for people as as the first time, half the
money is the first time and then the unemployment
benefits are half as big and they last for
only 11 weeks, about three months. So this
all counts on a dramatically strong recovery
that will be in full swing by March. And things
should be better by then as it starts getting
warmer again and people start being vaccinated
at a higher rate. But expecting anything approaching
a full recovery by three months from now seems
very silly. Some industries won't be fully
recovered for years. It is believed a huge
portion of small businesses are never reopening.
People are making zero right now. So much
like I said before, this was put together,
you know, if you're really struggling, six
hundred dollars isn't going to do much for
you at all. It's been seven months. You get
600 bucks. It's not enough for a month's rent
in almost any part of the country. The unemployment
payments won't be retroactive. So if you've
been out of a job for the last several months,
that that's just gone too bad it's not retroactive.
And there are some on the right who are saying.
You should be grateful that you got anything
the government doesn't owe you anything. Six
hundred dollars is 600 more than the government
owes you. Well, the idea of owing is sort
of strange, but consider that the government
allowed the pandemic to get this bad in the
first place. One of the worst responses in
the world from the Trump administration and
now it's everyone else who should be grateful
that they'll get 600 bucks, which is, of course,
paid out of our own tax money. Remember, despite
it being the government's fault that this
got so bad in the first place and had the
government handled this properly in a better
way, we wouldn't even need the degree of stimulus
that's now needed. And then on the tail end
of this, just the last thought that I have
on this, calling it a rescue package is almost
laughable. But there is some aspect of this
that makes me wonder, is Mitch McConnell and
are Republicans all of a sudden ready to get
this done quickly because they believe it
will help Kelly Lefler and David Perdue in
Georgia? And what I mean by that is we've
had the 2020 election. Trump lost, Biden won.
OK, Democrats retain control of the House,
albeit by a smaller margin than they had after
the twenty eighteen election. But control
of the Senate is still a question mark. Control
of the Senate. The Senate is still up for
grabs and it will depend on these two runoff
elections on January 5th in Georgia. Is this
an attempt to say, hey, look, Leffler and
Perdue delivered 600 bucks to you and more
unemployment money even to many voters in
Georgia, Republican Georgia voters who don't
even think the government should be giving
people anything? Is that part of the calculation
here? I don't know that that you know, with
Mitch McConnell, it's the answer is it's likely.
So it's been agreed upon. It's not yet been
voted on, will follow the process up to actually
being approved, if it will be. And then, of
course, who knows how many weeks or months
it would be until people actually get any
money